- [Narrator] Evan started giving
speeches at a Toronto YMCA.
Only three people showed up.
But those three
led to more.
- The amount of motivation,
inspiration and valuable insight
I've got from Evan
Carmichael's channel is crazy.
But most of all, thank you
for helping me believe.
- Thank you for helping me to understand
the power of having one word
and what a difference it can make.
- Thank you for all your
inspiring videos and articles.
- I'm so grateful for the opportunity
to be the part of the team.
It's so awesome to know
that work that you do
is needed and helps other people.
- Thank you for inspiring me
to take that leap of faith
from moving from Chicago out to California
to pursue my dreams as an actor.
- Help me feeling empowered
through tough times.
(soft music)
- I want to thank you from
the bottom of my heart.
You've helped make my life
so much more fulfilling.
- First of all, thank you
so much for showing me
new ways of starting a
business, new ways of selling.
- Thank you so much for helping
me find my one word, love.
God, I love it.
- Evan has helped me a lot by reminding me
that success is a product of perseverance.
- And thank you so much for
every thing that you do.
- I share your one word
with all of my clients.
- Thank you for showing us an importance
of leaving the comfort zone.
- And thank you for being real, man.
- Evan, thank you so much
for giving me a platform
to help me find out who
I'm truly supposed to be.
- Evan believes in you but he
backs it up with his actions.
And that is one of the
most amazing things.
- You advice on how to get focus
really means a lot to me every day.
So, really appreciate it.
- Thanks for the
motivation, the inspiration
to follow our dreams.
- I want to say thank
you for really helping me
in getting outside my comfort zone,
be in front of the camera.
- You gave me the opportunity
to do what I want.
And it's you that made me shine.
And most of all, thank you
for helping me believe.
- Hey Evan, happy birthday.
- Happy birthday from the swap.
- And happy birthday.
♫ Happy birthday dear Evan
- Happy birthday Evan.
- Birthday, Evan.
- Happy birthday brother.
- Happy birthday.
- Evan, happy birthday man.
- Wishing you a Happy birthday.
- Happy birthday Evan.
- I wanted to wish you
a very happy birthday.
- Very, merry, happy birthday.
- [Both] Happy birthday Evan.
(inspiring music)
- [Narrator] Evan's currently helped
over 20 million entrepreneurs.
But there's still a long way to go.
His dream is to help one billion.
And you can play a part.
Imagine all the dreams never realized.
Imagine all the goals never achieved.
Imagine all the people
this close to making it.
But gave up because they didn't believe.
Make a difference.
Introduce someone to Evan's channel today.
- Hey Evan, I used to be homeless,
living off cans of garbanzo
beans till I found your videos.
Now, I live with my mom.
Thank you for helping me believe.
- Should do a little
dab with that, you know.
- Bye.